so earlier in the program we covered the
fbi raid on rudy giuliani's house uh
apartment and office um and we are still
waiting to learn more about
what exactly is going on what crimes is
rudy suspected of and more information
about that i have to play some of these
clips for you
of rudy giuliani's son andrew giuliani
as well as just a random neighbor of
rudy's who seems to be straight out of
central casting
making statements to the media yesterday
outside rudy's uh
homer office we'll start with rudy's son
this is andrew giuliani
saying that uh what is going on here
should make it
it's all political and everybody should
be furious take a look at this
mind you i'm speaking as a son and a
concerned american
anybody any american whether you're red
or blue
should be extremely disturbed by what
happened here today
by the continued politicization of the
justice department
this is disgusting this is absolutely
absurd
and it's the continued politization of
the justice department that we have seen
so not exactly doing like a great job
there
and then this is just so funny andrew
giuliani says
there is important evidence in my
father's
uh home and office it's a hunter biden's
laptop
but the feds did not actually take that
the real evidence of crimes
andrew says i mean it's the apple does
not fall far from the tree
is hunter biden's laptop which they
didn't take the only piece of evidence
that they did not take up there today
was the only piece of incriminating
evidence
that is in there and it does not belong
to my father
it belongs to the current president's
son
they have figured out a way to make this
about hunter biden's laptop
somehow and i don't know that andrew
giuliani is really doing his dad any any
favors there now here's another funny
thing just for flavor
and and context one of rudy's neighbors
in the building she appears to be
straight out of central casting
she gave a statement it's not clear
whether she was just walking back from
getting groceries and stepped up to the
mic or if she was asked to come down i
mean this is just absolutely perfect
she expresses being amused when her
ex-husband called her and said hey
there's a raid going on there look out
your window the funniest thing is my
ex-husband called me
and said have you seen what's going on
and i i said he said no look out your
window
so here is more from rudy's neighbor
michelle herbert i love this woman i
know i just saw people i probably saw
fbi jackets
but i just saw people you know and i saw
all of you
and and i said
what is going on every detail
is just written for a movie and then on
fox news's the five
jessie waters i guess in a serious
manner suggests they really should have
raided
uh hunter biden's house not rudy
giuliani's take a look at this
jesse there when president trump was
impeached the first time
it was on the basis of putting pressure
on the ukrainian president to get
negative information on biden and i
think we're just running in a circle
here or back to that
incident what do you make of this
i think i speak for everybody on the
show when i say this
rudy giuliani is a national treasure
don't disagree i speak for everyone on
the show
when i say this the guy took on the mob
he took on crime
al-qaeda counselor to the president and
now democratic prosecutors want to lock
up a 76 year old
icon for a lobbying technicality one
because he advised the president he
should fire a rotten ambassador
you'd have to register to lobby for that
hunter biden advised his dad to fire a
prosecutor
did he register where's the raid on
hunter's house
i guess that's not comedy it's actually
now fox news has made it
complicated for us because now that
they have this comedy show gutfeld but
it's not funny
it's really hard to tell when you watch
something is this supposed to be a
comedy show
or not but jesse waters i don't think
that's a joke
saying really the rage should be of
hunter biden's house so i don't know if
that's comedy or a serious segment
but just every d if you wrote this into
a screenplay um
hollywood producers would say it's too
over the top just nobody it's it's
implausible
we need to make this less wacky but
unfortunately or maybe fortunately
it's the real story so we'll continue to
follow the situation with rudy giuliani
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25 percent off your first order
it's made with four key electrolytes
that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full
refund guarantee if you're not satisfied
and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video